bientôt nos excuses et je retrouve pour
un premier jeu n'aura avec le htc valdes
attention un jeu d'horreur on a ri gun
et va devoir buts et des vagues
d'ennemis gaillarde et ça c'est génial
la lampe torche et là et dans la vraie
vie elle est posée sur mon canapé la
manette je vais la prendre un plaisir si
je vous propose c'est de se mettre en
mode commando d'accord je peux allumé ou
éteint maoussa et bouille
on a beaucoup d'humour je vais la
prendre en main leur tactique c'est
comme les flics ont testé une
perquisition tapé un caillou tab le fdp
sutout stark première vague alors ici à
tout un petit matou soit pas se mentir
et 1 n'est d'aucun ok alors les pages
sont précieuses la langue haché 2 on est
heureux
oui je vais rien et je crois qu'ils
arrivent tout autour d'eux joue c'est
très piégeux mais en aucun cas s'il a
regardé la barre de tâches trop con je
dispute ou mal en hockey en allah et un
juste à côté ok c'est parti je suis venu
que je peine capitale y en a 3 [ __ ]
[ __ ] ou pas je m'en charge
webb a fait sursauter via mabiala vient
après auplata tête elle a sauté j'ai
super corps ça me touche je recherche
moi que je peux le vrai mais c'est qu'on
a eu deux balles très limité vraiment je
m'approche 2 intéressant c'est
intéressant tu me raconteras plus tard
ce qui s'est passé dans cet avion le 18
avril
jean-michel aveugle ok on est pas mal
j'ai fait le malheur j'ai vraiment
regretté ya quoi ya pas d'émission
là-dedans mike et au je pourrais rien
faire
ok ok tu meurs tu le sais et c'est parti
on part sur un 2e pic ni d'odos hockey
un troisième et j'envoie mon droit je
pourrais des théories sont il m'a foutu
une pression l'automne suivant
attention c'est vraiment comme ça la
position adéquate pour tuer mon c'est ça
je vous ment même pas atteint sans
brigands aller et il n'était pas loin ça
je suis essoufflée
non mon coeur va très très fort vous
avez survécu aux plaisirs selecta noble
trade une grenade un point rouge [ __ ]
on veut toucher à grenade à elle à
grenade à la deuxième vague on vous
attend y est comme un chewing gum admis
on a eu trois balles par mons je pense
qu'on va vite est à court de balles on
va pas se mentir alors lui une forme
éprouvée resserre et bien la tête il ya
plus de problème à léran bâle iii chez
ge a voulu mais un poster je vais pas
faire le mec
ok ok d'état sous contrôle était sous
contrôle
tout est sous contrôle
légal on n'est pas mal ah c'est une
grosse vague là on est passé d'une
wagonnets tu as eu un tsunami aura pas
se mentir en un choix entre quoi des
nouvelles batteries de flash lite
une autre grenade ou un laser ça il veut
nous refiler le hajj hassan
on va prendre les batteries c'est plus
intelligent voilà cette fois je me sens
moins twinzer salle ok jazz je peux pas
manger ces médicaments pour aller mieux
mais non mais non
o o
a pattaya à la grenade mais un trop loin
je me suis tué leur thèse je fais le
coût de leur taille comment tu me
restait dans l'air de jeu constructeu
course de super à léon journaux flamands
roses on bat les couilles
on est un agent secret unijambiste qui y
voit un problème ok ça dégage ok mais
pas mal
eh ben ali kader vous avez survécu on va
prendre les munitions on va jouer la
sécurité avec comme matmour i'm waiting
for you
un one même pas tu me teste ok ça
c'était au fait c'est quoi cette
approche boufigue à leïla qui sert aux
très bien j'avais tellement de styles
que mon pc a buggé donc on va partir sur
un carnage
j'ai tout mis à côté une énorme de merde
pire après l'alsace taille pour prendre
notre revanche c'est parti beach c'est
pas vrai pour voir mon visage mais c'est
pas souhaité le doigt de pied ne pas
vous mentir rien gros ya le groupe cari
yakro karine hoyez là ok je cherche je
cherche je cherche du boulot à faire
changer leur fais bien la chaleur se
trouvent les routes souvent en aval
l'acier moi c'était un peu ça pleure je
vois pas se mentir je t'ai pas vu
ce calme j'aimerais tant avoir un sens
regardez regardez ouais désolé je
regardais pas moi c'est tous les mecs
ils ont tout donné [ __ ] ok c'est
injuste je foutais là d'ailleurs c'est
une bonne question
y'a du scotch à mes pieds et un sac de
couchage mais vous les compromis les
démons c'est un vrai plaisir
ça c'est fait ça s'est fait à l'égaler
dia je sais plus quoi faire là
franchement c'est trop facile
out of à mon nom mais non mais non mais
pas du tout et ben voyons je m'en bats
les c est que je fais bouffer mon gars
vas-y approchez-vous vas-y vas-y bien
déjà déjà je savais qu'avec ce laser
pour commencer tiens tiens ça marche ça
dégage
super ouais je dis au point de cette
vidéo c'était lara croft j'espère sera
plus n'hésitez pas venez au sénat plutôt
d'habitude à expliquer c'est un très bon
jeu voilà beau graphiquement on a envie
d'avoir des trucs qui envoie du lourd
dès le début il va falloir être un petit
peu patient je pense ça m'a fait un peu
peur ça fait bizarre de redécouvrir le
monde
voilà maintenant je retombe dans le br
on se croisait une prochaine des
commerces avons regardé porte et julien
chez tout le monde
pis
oh